alors il fait maintenant partie de notre
vie depuis plusieurs années d'ailleurs
c'est un geste
j'imagine naturel chez vous à la maison
les enfants encore plus certains parents
donc bacs de recyclage on recycle on
recycle et c'est tant mieux
jean-sébastien cloutier ont d'abord se
poser la question il ya plusieurs
semaines est ce que c'est efficace on
verra
différents éléments ce soit pour
répondre à ces questions là il ya de
nouveaux chiffres qui sont sortis donc
il ya quelques jours qu'ils sont plutôt
encourageants des chiffres rendus
publics par la communauté métropolitaine
de montréal donc qui prennent la moyenne
des 80 2002 82 villes du grand montréal
et oui c'est encourageant on a trois
tableaux pour vous d'abord la quantité
de déchets domestiques ni aux vidanges
parler j'en voyais en 2006 c'était 4 117
kg par année en 2012 s'était 335 alors
c'est une belle amélioration et on
suppose que ça continue de descendre
année après année autre chiffre
intéressant un patrice le taux de
récupération des matières recyclables ce
qui se retrouve qui doit se retrouver
dans nos bacs en 2006 c'était 46 % en
2012 on était à 50 9%
à noter là dessus que l'objectif était
d'atteindre 60 % pour 2011 alors il ya
peut-être un retard de deux ans parce
qu'on imagine que l'an dernier
en 2013 on a atteint 60 pour ça donc on
met à peu près 60% de ce qui se recycle
dans nos bacs
il est quand même 40 pour ça qu'on met
encore dans les poubelles a donc produit
au gour peine de l'ex et ce qui est
intéressant et c'est ce qui va peut-être
faire en sorte que les choses vont
changer plus rapidement
c'est que ça coûte maintenant moins cher
recycler une tonne que enter into
intéressant et ça ça a changé la partir
de 2012 justement environ d'économies
d'échelle entre autres on imagine alors
regardez les chiffres donc le coût de
récupération d'une tonne de matière
recyclée ça ça veut dire à partir du
trottoir jusqu'au ballots de papier ou
de plastique 150 dollars la tonne et le
coup de récupération de matières jeter
éliminé au dépotoir 170 dollars la tonne
on s'est promené on est allé voir d
entre eux
reese qui travaille dans le milieu du
recyclage on est allé voir des centres
de tri et on a constaté qu'il y avait
une problématique que beaucoup de gens
décrié patrice les gens risquent
peut-être plus mais ils prennent souvent
leur bac pour une poubelle
on dirait qu'ils ont pas encore tout à
fait compris pas tout le monde mais
beaucoup jouent effectivement un garde
temps via près du trottoir aux camions
le contenu des bacs et des sacs de
recyclage des montréalais prennent le
chemin du centre de tri de la ville dans
saint michel
c'est ici que se retrouve tout ce qui se
recycle à montréal et laval et hors
cycle plus que jamais je voudrais que le
centre de tri recevait au début des
années 2000 environ 80 milles tonnes de
matière par année et on est rendu
aujourd'hui
mais il y un problème et il est en
hausse lui aussi de plus en plus à
montréal comme ailleurs au québec ont
rempli les bacs de n'importe quoi
la problématique c'est 15% de ce qui se
retrouve à l'intérieur d'une balle
piquée non visés par le bec
la collecte sélective au centre de
montréal c'est dans cette salle que
s'effectue le premier tri des produits
les employés retire ce qui ne peut pas y
être recyclés et on trouve de tout à
preuve ce tas de déchets amassés juste à
côté bonbonnes de gaz tpiy oreiller le
batterie de voiture
la conscientisation sur ça veut dire
quoi récupérer et comment c'est bon pour
l'environnement est tout le monde veut
participer à ce fake ont amené cette
popularité le roi ce que hp / je m
intéresse bac pour moi ça fait sens mais
le mot d'ordre de recyc québec est
plutôt dans le doute ne mettez pas votre
produit dans le bac
chez cascades dans les bois francs le
plus gros recycleurs de papier au pays
on pense que bien des villes devraient
mieux sensibiliser leurs citoyens les
gens devraient être informés à la base
au minimum de ce qu'ils peuvent mettre
dans le bac s qui ne peut pas mettre
dans le bac vous allez voir tantôt dans
les matières qu'on va vous montrer qu'il
ya des choses qui etc c'est incroyable
petite échantillonnage de ce que le
centre de tri qui fournit l'entreprise a
refait y quelques jours avant notre
visite
et voyez les gens parce que on peut
récupérer des totaux on peut récupérer
des bouts de bois on peut récupérer des
bonbonnes donc vous voyez que les gens
encore un peu de travail et même ici le
matin on a mal des seringues souillées
qu'on retrouve dans la récupération
selon mario plourde la discipline dans
le recyclage n'est d'ailleurs pas la
force des montréalais
quand on arrive dans les si tu fais ça
multilogements la poubelle appartient à
personne et le bac de recyclage
appartient à personne donc la qualité
qu'on y retrouve à l'intérieur du bac
elle est très variable et normalement il
ya beaucoup plus de rejet et de
matériaux fendt massey bachelot depuis
quelques années le gestionnaire du
centre de tri de montréal estime que le
nombre de ces matières rejetées a doublé
passant de 5 à 10 % de tout ce qui est
recueilli et il y un coup à cela c'est
une facture au québec de l'ordre de 23
millions $ qui est payé en partie par
les entreprises font de la mise en
marché et les municipales dès après
demain d'heures supplémentaires et on a
des équipements mécaniques qui
malheureusement ne sont pas conçus pour
accueillir ces types de matières donc ça
provoque des bourrages des bris
d'équipement effectivement ça coûte plus
cher
oui des comportements un petit peu plus
délicat à montréal dit réal ménard
il n'y a pas eu de grandes campagnes de
sensibilisation depuis au moins cinq ans
on essaye à des moments très précis de
faire de rappeler un peu des consignes
qu'est ce qui vaut au recyclage pour est
important de pas hambourg b lorsque ça
devrait pas l'objet d'interventions plus
récurrentes peut-être pour lui recyclé
recyc québec invite la population à
s'informer sur son site
recréer point c'est alors jean sébastien
une fois qu'on a enlevé le 15 pour cent
de choses qui ne devraient pas aller
dans notre bac
qu'est ce qui arrive et c'est une la
grande question avec effectivement ce
que l'on met dans notre bac ce que cet
intérêt en cash à tous effectivement ça
va mieux là ça va ça va mieux c'est pas
une industrie qui est facile de ses
serments mais ça vaut mieux
contrairement il ya quelques années
si vous habitez montréal où laval parce
que c'est là que s'est déroulée une
étude notre reportage tout ce que vous
mettez dans votre bac va se faire d'une
manière ou d'une autre
recyclés par exemple le papier le papier
c'est 70% des ventes en fait 70% des
revenus des entreprises et le plus
facile donc le film les fibres à
montréal le papier sans en chine
alors ça sambre en chine c'est pas
compliqué dans une proportion de 90 %
environ
le carton vous recyclez va se retrouver
dans une proportion de 50% environ à
l'extérieur et autrement peut-être chez
cascades cascade qui écoute et re sic je
pense j'ai le chef ici dix huit mille
tonnes je lis 1.8 million de tonnes par
contre pardon de cartons qu'admet manque
de papier pour recycler importe du
papier des états unis pour oui
effectivement cascades va
un même son papier de toilette ses
papiers suite aux états unis revient
avec des trains et des camions bondés de
papier le plastique par exemple le métal
mais encore là c'est des parents il ya
une semaine qui est une entreprise un
recycleur de plastiques qui va offrir
plus alors le centre de tri va leur
vendre son ballot une autre semaine
c'est une autre entreprise par exemple
le plastique des bouteilles d'eau peut
être récupérée pour faire du tissu dans
les polars par exemple des exemples
comme ça
le vert par contre une problématique il
y en a eu une l'an dernier
particulièrement d un gros tas de verre
on dirait qu'on le vende pas
effectivement et on a dû d'ailleurs on
enfouit ça c'est vrai à un certain
moment l'an dernier a eu 18 mille tonnes
entreposés au centre de tri en fait
jusqu'en décembre dernier parce que la
seule entreprise qui recycler le verre
dans la région de montréal offert mais
on n'est pas comme en italie en france
on n'a pas de beaucoup on n'est pas
producteur de verre lors c'est difficile
de s'en débarrasser là on a trouvé un
contrat avec bébé fille de lachenaie qui
est en fait un site d'enfouissement
alors on peut peut-être dire que cela
pourrait servir autrement mais là au
moins le site d'enfouissement
l'utilisent par exemple pour la chaussée
pour ses camions dans le site
d'enfouissement
mais il ya peut-être l'espoir les façon
polie je ne sais pas si elle de dire
qu'on est entrain de l'enfouir du verre
tout d'en faire un produit innovateur
scapa des pistes là dessus il ya de
l'espoir une entreprise tricentris qui
sur la rive nord on a la chair de
l'université de sherbrooke qui est allé
d'une innovation en fait de la poudre de
verre qu'on pense qu'ils pourraient être
utilisés dans le mélange de béton elle
il ya des tests qui se font certains
trottoirs montréalais certains planchers
qui se sont fait avec ça se formeraient
du béton plus résistants alors qui sait
il faut créer la demande faut créer le
marché par c'est pas une industrie qui
est facile d'ailleurs je vous laisse là
dessus patrice le centre de tri lui a
fait de l'argent depuis 2008 seulement
en 2011 lors d'une seule année
alors c'est un marché qui est pas facile
pour ni pour les recycleurs ni pour les
centres de tri à suivre le vert donc il
ya aussi cette question que l'on pose
épisodiquement c'est les bouteilles la
saq ce qu'on ne devrait pas les
consignes et ça revient souvent
ça revient souvent c'est du verre coloré
c'est plus difficile également
merci beaucoup jean-sébastien mais
carmen ont conclu à de l'espoir - au
départ j'étais je croyais que certains
produits les amplis c'est beaucoup plus
régulièrement faute de débouchés
or ça semble pas être le cas sauf le
verre merci à la prochaine